Haven't you ever wondered what else is out there
there's wonders in this world beyond our
i can feel it
Welcome back everyone this will be my lord of the
rings super bowl trailer video for the rings of
power tv show that's starting later this year as
the title implies it'll cover how sauron created
the rings of power or tricked the races of middle
earth into creating the rings of power and the one
ring it's going to take place much earlier in the
timeline thousands of years before the events of
the movies so i'll explain who everyone is and
what the plot is and what amazon is changing
from the books that sort of compress thousands of
years of history into like 10 seasons of a show
there's a bunch of easter eggs a bunch of
familiar characters even though some of the
actors are different some of the characters are
the same characters that show up during the movies
so we'll break it all down i'll be doing episode
videos for it when it premieres in september so
be sure to subscribe to get everything when the
episodes get here too i'll do special lord of the
rings giveaways amazon prime memberships when it
starts but this first teaser trailer is just meant
to show you a quick look at most but not all of
the major characters as far as i can tell sauron
is not featured anywhere in any of this footage
he was called annatar during this period of the
timeline i'll get into that in a second but
there was a lot of confusion when they dropped
the trailer because some of the characters that
they've announced for the series were alive during
very different parts of the timeline during the
second age when this takes place so the actual
second age of middle earth covers thousands of
years of history but because they're covering
pretty much all the major events of the second
age during the tv show they have to compress a
lot of that so there's a lot of characters that
were alive during different parts of the timeline
that will overlap on the show but if you're
wondering why you don't see sauron with the one
ring of power in this trailer at this point in the
timeline where the show picks up he hasn't created
it yet or the other rings of power there were
19 rings plus the one ring for 20 rings of power
total that is a lot of power for the most part
the look the tone that they're going for with the
series will feel very similar to the lord of the
rings movies special effects have gotten better
the last several years since the hobbit movies
happened since the original lord of the rings
movies howard shore is also coming back to work
on the music with bear mcqueary so the music the
soundtrack will also sound similar to the movies
and even though amazon only has the tv rights for
the lord of the rings stuff during the second
age they don't have the rights to do any of the
movie stuff yet the people who do own the movie
rights are actually putting them up for sale real
soon so amazon might get those too and start doing
more lord of the rings movies in the future so if
you're a huge tolkien fan big fan of the lord of
the rings you're going to be eating good for the
next 20 years or so but as i said the series
takes place during the second age about 2000
years before the events of the movies actually i
think it's a little bit more than that it's many
thousands of years the reason why there are so
many characters from the movies like galadriel
and elrond on the series these characters here is
because elves are functionally immortal so some
of the characters will be similar to the ones in
the movies but for example gandalf will not be a
character during this series because during this
part of the timeline the wizards had not been sent
to middle earth yet a wizard is never late nor
is he early he arrives precisely when he means
gandalf and the group of wizards that he was a
part of didn't come to middle earth till about
a thousand years into the third age a long
long time after all the stuff they're going
to be covering on the show galadriel is one of
the main characters on the show that's why she's
featured so heavily in all these different trailer
scenes there's a lot of galadriel in this footage
much younger version of the character played
by a different actress but it is galadriel
when the plot picks up she's going to be hunting
down sauron in the remnants of his master morgoth
melkor's army whichever name you want to use for
him he has many different names sauron also had
many different names we'll get some of them
during the events of this series just like we
got a prologue at the beginning of fellowship of
the ring that showed the war of the last alliance
against sauron where they defeated him we'll
also probably get some kind of prologue scene
at the beginning of the series which will cover
the war of wrath which was like the last big war
at the end of the first stage before the second
age started the war of wrath was their war against
melkor who's kind of like the lord of the rings
universe version of lucifer he was sauron's master
he was the first person to try and conquer middle
earth all the other races teamed up to fight him
they defeated him banished him to this abyss this
other dimension outside the main lord of the rings
dimension sauron slinks away and then develops his
plan to trick the races of men create the rings of
power and then start his war for middle earth the
first stage ended with the war of wrath which was
kind of like that era's version of the war of the
ring the one you saw take place during the movies
the second age the one they're covering during
the show ended with isildur basically cutting the
one ring off of sauron's hand with the shard
of narsil what amazon is doing is condensing
the second age timeline like i said thousands of
years of history into several seasons of the show
so i believe their plan is to end the show
like whatever the final season winds up being
with the war of the last alliance the war that you
see in the prologue of the fellowship where they
actually defeat sauron there was a war before
that called the war of elves and sauron which
took place earlier in the timeline which they
might merge with the war of the last alliance if
they're condensing everything there were a couple
wars they fought with sauron when he was creating
the rings of power but i think that's going to be
like their game of thrones war for the dawn type
of event that they build up to sauron being their
version of the night king but the big difference
is that unlike the night king on game of thrones
the white walkers during this era of the lord
of the rings timeline sauron was hiding in plain
sight amongst the races of middle-earth the elves
the dwarves nobody knew that it was sauron because
after sauron's master melkor morgoth was defeated
banished to the void sauron still looked like
this like pretty boy sauron his armor didn't look
all scary and hardcore until the war of the last
alliance he slinked away used his magic to change
his appearance and start using the name annatar
he presented himself to kelebrimbor this legendary
elf who was the last of this really special
group of elves the super long tragic backstory
that's too long for this video he comes to keller
brimbore pretending to be this annatar character
pretending to be an emissary of the aenor with
the promise of these rings of power meant to
give all these races much more power the aener
were these primordial cosmic beings that wielded
god tier power and shape middle earth created
the different races animals plants everything
to make biblical references they're kind
of like the different castes of angels like
there are higher choirs of angels angels that
are more powerful than others like archangels
fun fact too sauron and gandalf come from the
exact same subgroup of these primordial beings
they were called mayor they're like a lesser group
of angels within these different tiers of angels
but within their subgroup sauron was more powerful
than gandalf when they're on middle earth they're
really just like these angelic beings taking human
form they just go back to their original form if
their human bodies get killed that's why sauron
doesn't completely die when a sealed cuts the
ring off his hand his spirit survives is the same
thing with gandalf remember they come from the
same group of these primordial beings so that's
how gandalf can also come back to life so to speak
take another human form in present day during the
events of the movies just like sauron comes back
and even though a lot of people think of sauron
is like the end-all be-all of evil on middle-earth
the movies kind of portray him that way the
characters talk about him as if he is the ultimate
evil his master melkor was from a way higher
cast of even more powerful primordial beings
melkor like i said was kind of like the lord of
the rings universe version of lucifer he was one
of the original angelic primordial beings created
by the god of the lord of the rings universe
sauron gandalf all the other lesser primordial
beings with all this god tier power didn't really
come along until later so when the episodes
pick up this major war of wrath against melkor
sauron their forces has just been won but their
forces scattered to the four winds sauron's still
alive so galadriel takes it on herself to hunt
them down the character here on the raft who
helps save her is a human character named hal
brand he's not from the books he's like a new
character they created for the show who just
winds up helping galadriel hunt down sauron
during all the trailer footage all these
scenes of galadriel that you see with her
having adventures going all over the place
all these action scenes are during various
stages of her hunt to find sauron this is the
young version of elrond on the series the actor
might look familiar he also played young ned
stark during game of thrones during the events
of this series in this part of the timeline of
middle earth elrond's main mission is to repair
diplomatic relations between the elves and the
dwarves of kazudum we visited kazadoom during
the fellowship of the ring after had been taken
over by the balrog and the orcs much later in
the timeline but during this era kazudum was still
thriving and being ruled over by during the third
this is during the fourth during the show he's
one of the main characters he's just a prince
when the plot picks up this female character
sitting on the dwarven throne is princess diesa
she's also not somebody from the book she's like
a new dwarven princess they created for the show
this female character is the show's version of
a hobbit she's a har foot there were no actual
hobbits during this part of the timeline in the
second age they didn't show up until the third age
the race that they evolved from was called the har
foots but during these episodes you can think of
her as the show's version of a hobbit there's also
this really big mystery character that they've
been hyping up during the scene with all the fire
you see her reaching her hand out the hard foot
reaching her hand out to grab this older man's
hand this shaggy beard they haven't said who he
is only that he's got this really big mysterious
backstory and his origin will be a big storyline
on the show for those of you that are thinking of
gandalf theories like anytime you see an old man
with a giant beard with a mysterious backstory
you think of gandalf i don't expect him to be
gandolf like i said gandalf didn't come to middle
earth till like thousands of years later in the
timeline but if they're compressing the timeline
they could always bend over backwards to get some
kind of wizard onto the show because it would be
weird to see a giant tv show go on for 10 years
without any wizards of any kind this elf here
is gilgalad he's the high king of all the elves
of middle earth now there are different groups of
elves different clans that descend from different
lines but he was viewed as the highest authority
over all of them during this part of the timeline
the city that he rules from is called linden
this area where the scene is taking place the
waterfront city at the beginning of the trailer as
a lot of you might have guessed is numenor this is
a real huge deal because during the second age the
new minorians got into that big war with the valor
when sauron tricked them quote unquote this is
a familiar theme sauron tricking people into
their own downfall he tricked the numenoreans into
invading the undying lands in a louvitar the true
god of the lord of the rings universe basically
just plucked the undying lands separating it from
the rest of the planet causing this massive shift
in the geography these giant tidal waves sinking
the entire island of numenor that's what they call
the downfall of numenor maybe they'll cover that
on the show it's such a huge event i don't see
how they could not do it on the show at some point
the line of kings of numenor did survive because
in present day in the timeline of the movies
aragorn is the last descendant of the original
numenorean kings bringing things back around
to elrond and the other characters on the show
there's a lot of connections here too because
the way elves live for so long the reason why
aragorn lives for so long why numenoreans in
general live for so long is because they all have
elven blood in their veins to various degrees
numenor the kingdom was created by elrond's
brother elros he was the first king of numenor
even though elves can basically be functionally
immortal elrond's brother chose to die after
about 400 years but if they're compressing the
timeline maybe we'll see him create numenor in
flashbacks i think in present day because they
probably want to do the downfall of numenor the
main king of numenor at the time will be the
king who presided over the downfall of numenor
his name was r ferrazone there are a couple other
lesser characters during the trailer i'll talk
more about them when we get our next trailer with
a bunch more footage like i said this trailer just
mostly meant to give you a general vibe for the
series give you a sense for when the episodes take
place in the timeline and the really fan favorite
familiar characters like galadriel and elrond what
they'll probably do though is they'll probably
save the big sauron annatar reveal whatever he's
going to look like on the show for much later like
when we get closer to the series actually coming
out if you ever watched the daredevil netflix
series they didn't actually reveal the kingpin
character you'd actually see him on screen till a
little bit later in the episodes it'll probably be
the same thing with sauron during the lord of the
rings tv series but if you spotted any huge easter
eggs that i didn't talk about in the video that
you have questions about or anything just write
them below in the comments everyone click here
for my new marvel doctor strange multiverse of
madness trailer video from the super bowl and
click here for my brand new moon knight trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!